could this growing business survive an
unexpected tragedy 1031 production
started off strong but where is the
company today on Shark Tank most pitches
fall into familiar categories like
household goods technology child care
products or food it's relatively rare
for the Sharks to consider pitches in
the entertainment realm yes there have
been a few exceptions like the
inclusivity oriented Comics company
Black Sands Productions there's also dri
suits robotic car themed strolling
performance Venture however companies
like 1031 Productions are a relative
anomaly the brainchild of entrepreneur
Melissa Carbone 1031 Productions began
as a company that stages live horror
themed events their most popular
attraction is the Los Angeles haunted
hay ride a terrifying nighttime trip
through several scary Tableau set up in
the city's famed Griffith Park Carbone
and her business partner and ex spouse
Allison Richards launched 1031
Productions in 2009 by the time of her
Shark Tank pitch 1031 Productions most
lucrative Revenue stream came from the
haunted hay ride each October the
haunted hay ride was operational for the
17 days leading up to Halloween it
consistently sold out adding up to about
$1.8 million in Revenue in that period
alone Carbone went into the tank to
pitch her company in October 2013 with
her episode airing 6 days before
Halloween she asked for $2 million in
exchange for a 10% Equity stake in her
company Kevin o and Robert HC didn't
believe in her financial projections for
the following year while Lori grineer
didn't consider the investment worth her
time so all three bowed out Damon John
offered $2 million for 40% but when
Carbone countered with the same dollar
amount for 20% Mark Cuban swooped in and
took the deal and with that it was his
biggest investment in his first five
seasons on the show everywhere I go
there's zombies 1031 had big plans for
expansion including a New York based
haunted hay ride as well as a great
horror camp out an immersive 12-hour
campon filled with scares bigger picture
Carbone wanted to have a 1031 attraction
in every major city in the US the first
New York haunted hay ride was a success
in its first year it made 36 6% more
than its Los Angeles counterparts
second-year performance even if bad
weather meant that it fell short of its
$5 million goal this along with Cuban's
investment allowed 1031 to Branch out as
of May 2015 it offered two hay rides the
camping attraction a haunted Cruise
called the Ghost Ship several great
horror movie night outings and even a
film production company that aimed to
make movies related to its attractions
the popularity of 1031 Productions and
its numerous Affiliated attractions has
turned it into one of the biggest shark
tank success stories out there
of course not every big leap of faith
that Mark Cuban or any of the other
sharks have taken on an investment deal
has turned out so Rosy so it's worth
looking closer at how everything came
together in this unique case as touched
upon prior 1031 Productions was actually
doing quite well even before it got
featured on Shark Tank between having
several established Brands and a solid
stream of Revenue the business was in no
need of a savior Melissa Carbone told
dread Central in a 2017 interview we
were doing really well and I had little
to no interest in selling a piece of the
company I recognized what the platform
Shark Tank could provide so I
reconsidered indeed arguably the
greatest effect of Cuban's involvement
with 1031 Productions is how it allowed
the venture to carry out its
pre-existing plans for expansion more
efficiently in the interview Carbone
noted the amount of time that
opportunity saves us on sourcing
location scouting and Partnerships has
been incredible it took a year to permit
a location for our first attraction and
once we became known and associated with
Mark everyone in the country with a
piece of land or building to offer had
us on speed dial it seems that 10 1
Productions was bound for Success
regardless of whether it obtained a deal
on Shark Tank or not unfortunately not
everything was smooth sailing for the
growing company the New York Post
reported that back in 2016 one of the
haunted hay ride set pieces supposedly a
fog machine fell on a customer leaving
them severely injured this led to a
lawsuit in 2018 and as a result Carbone
sold 1031 to a vent company 13th floor
Entertainment Group with that said she
is still actively operating her rides
and events through the new
company